there's no doubt i think the democrats
have really fallen in love with the
monopoly power of these companies and if
you listen to those hearings
and uh cover them as you did you would
you hear over and over is the democrats
saying the companies ought to censor
more yeah
they have to use their power more
aggressively i mean they're no longer
worried about the concentration of power
they're basically cheering the companies
on and then threatening
to regulate them if the companies don't
get more sensorious which is sort of
hard to imagine
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the junior senator from the great state
of missouri
and the author of the new book the
tyranny of big tech
senator josh hawley welcome to the
reuben report thanks for having me
senator what are the chances that this
video is not going to be
algorithmically depressed by youtube do
we have any chance that anyone's going
to see this thing
i i don't know given my history with big
tech
maybe not but we'll keep our fingers
crossed i've got a similar history
with big tech so i want to start by i
just literally in the last five minutes
as we sat down with you i saw two
headlines that i thought okay these are
these are perfect
to tee up for the senator so breitbart
is just reporting in the last couple of
minutes
that i'll read you the exact uh tweet
twitter is reportedly developing
a feature to make users reconsider
sending messages that its system detects
as quote mean
i suspect i suspect that will include a
lot of your stuff
well i suspect what will happen is well
first of all if they actually enforce
that wouldn't that shut down all of
twitter
that's it for twitter twitter seems to
subsist on
but uh of course i in practice i'm sure
that will mean that uh conservatives and
libertarians that their tweets
are all silenced and the left can can go
on with the hate-mongering as long as
they like that's usually how it works
yeah that that pretty much is it and
then this other one which
it seems obvious and i actually warned
that this was going to be coming
twitter is now this is from becker news
twitter is now suspending users who
share
donald trump's statements so as you know
trump launched ineffective blog it
wasn't sort of
people were saying he was going to come
out with this big platform apparently
that's not it
but he launched this thing with just
buttons that could send stuff to twitter
and facebook
now they're actually deleting accounts
that just
link to his stuff yeah that's just
it's unbelievable and their their
determination
to completely silence and erase and
cancel
the former president of the united
states it just it's just shocking and
the fact that they
have the power the monopoly power to do
this
and to get by with it and that there's
nowhere else the former president can go
i mean think about this former president
united states had what
78 and 80 million followers or something
on twitter and
many more on the other platforms and
there's no alternative
for him to go he's got to try and create
his own thing i mean
that tells you something about the
monopoly power of these companies okay
so let's start right at the heart of it
because you are a constitutional
conservative and
at least as far as i know we're still
governed by the constitution although
i'm not quite sure these days but i know
that a lot of people
every time you say okay we've got to do
something about big tech
they say well what do you mean they're
private companies and
we should just leave them alone what is
your argument against that
well listen a monopoly is a threat to
the free market and also a threat to
liberty i mean this is the problem for
those of us who believe in free market
capitalism
is that monopoly stifles competition
midnight monopoly raises barriers to
entry
raises uh barriers to new entrants into
the market slows down
innovation and of course gives the
holders of the monopoly
incredible power in politics and we're
seeing that now
with these big tech companies so i would
just say to those who consider
themselves
defenders of the free market to those
who consider themselves defenders of
capitalism that it is incumbent upon
us to dismantle monopolies so that the
market can function
we could have more competition consumers
could have more choice
bottom line politically is our front our
framers understood
monopoly and liberty do not go together
and we've got to recover that
understanding
do you think in some sense though the
ship has just kind of sailed here you
know i covered all the hearings
obviously you you were very involved in
all of those
and when trump was in power there was
this idea that oh maybe something's
going to happen
but at this point biden's in charge and
the democrats
are in charge and it's like well why
would they do anything on this stuff
because
it's helping them yeah there's no doubt
i think the democrats have really fallen
in love with the monopoly power of these
companies and if you listen to those
hearings
and cover them as you did you would you
hear over and over is the democrats
saying the companies ought to censor
more
yeah they have to use their power more
aggressively i mean they're no longer
worried about the concentration of power
they're basically cheering the companies
on and then threatening
to regulate them if the companies don't
get more sensorious which is sort of
hard to imagine
but i do think that the democrats have
have really given up
uh on the monopoly question because
they've come to love it but that doesn't
mean that the conservatives have to i
mean we have to now more than ever
get back to their founders understanding
that monopoly and liberty are not
compatible and what we need is more
competition
what we need is to return power and
control to the american people
that includes control over your own
speech control over your own personal
information your personal data
and i think we've got to be bold in
pushing forward reforms and legislative
proposals that will do that
why do you think trump didn't move on
this you know there was this threat of
doing something about section 230 of the
communications act that we've covered a
million times before
but nothing happened what do you think
was the hold up there
i think that really the the white house
didn't get focused on it and uh
the president i think did not begin to
really push it until until it was in an
election season and it was very hard
then at that point
to galvanize congress into action but
also i the real sticking point was never
the white house it was always congress
and a lot of listen when i came to
the senate just two years ago and i
began proposing uh to reform overhaul
section 230
to break up these monopolies i couldn't
find very many takers on my side of the
aisle i mean there were
very very few republicans who wanted to
be associated with that or involved with
that
and so i think you just didn't have a
lot of enthusiasm and that's because
republican elected officials were a lot
of the times
out of step with their own voters their
own voters are saying wow
these companies have too much power they
are
radical left they are censoring speech
they are shutting down our speech in the
democratic process interfering with it
but you said republicans who weren't
willing to move on
i think that that is changing but as you
say the last
two four years were really a missed
opportunity for republicans in that
respect and now we've got to make up for
lost time and we can
do that by being bold with our thinking
bold in our proposals
and go to the american people with an
agenda to trust bust
here in the 21st century but do you fear
that now that the democrats are in
charge that
if they were to do anything about all of
this that it would actually just be
worse because you made the point
they were basically saying hey if you
guys don't regulate speech we're going
to punish you i mean that's basically
what aoc
said to zuckerberg and he pretty much
was like well i can't i can't do that
i'm not god
but now that they have the power like
it's hard for me to envision basically
them using that power
to expand freedom yes i i
agree with you i think this is one of
the reasons why i'm very very skeptical
of increasing government regulation over
the companies especially the way the
democrats want to you know democrats
want to further regulate the speech
content
that's on uh that's on the web that's on
these platforms i mean that's what they
really want to do and they want to tell
the companies
that you need to define this as
offensive and you need to find that as
threatening and you need to take down
this
that i think is exactly the wrong way to
go we don't need less speech we need
more speech we don't need more political
control
we need less political control and more
freedom
on the internet and everywhere else so i
think that the way to go
is not to increase the government
involvement but to break the companies
up i mean let's get the free market
involved again let's get some
competitors
in that space another thing i would say
is let's give people the right to sue
these companies these monopolies
if they get de-platformed and they're
treated in bad faith you know it used to
be i mean it still is true in every
other
walk of life of their every other
industry that if a company violates its
contract with you
you can sue them well with big tech you
can't sue them if they violate their
terms of agreement
because the federal government protects
them immunizes them that's section 230.
i think we ought to withdraw that and
allow people to
sue if the if they're treated in bad
faith by these companies
if these companies violate their terms
of service i think that could be a game
changer
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell